hey what's up guys mkbhd here and today
was the first day of Google's i/o 2012
conference which is basically the haven
for all new things Google today one of
the conference's usually where they
introduce the best of the best the
newest of the new it's basically like a
mini WWDC in one day for for Google it's
really awesome conference so without any
further ado let's take a look at the
best of what happened today on day one
Google started right off with Android
4.1 yes Android 4.1 is jelly bean now
and it's officially official as if it
wasn't rumored enough already
Android 4.1 has a ton of new
improvements and it's coming with a an
interesting punch that it's packing but
we'll get to that in a second so
basically they started off by saying
they want to make the entire operating
system a more smooth and more fluid
experience with project butter which
makes sense because smooth is butter
yeah ok
they show some comparisons with
ice-cream sandwich next to jelly bean
which would be 4.0 next to 4.1 and they
mentioned that they have the entire
frame rate of the entire operating
system at 60 frames per second so
hopefully that's I mean that sounds
really really good to me hopefully they
can actually make that realistic with
the devices that come out in the future
but that sounds really good the entire
device is supposed to be smooth and from
the animations and things that they saw
during the demo it looks like it's
actually the case Android as we already
know also has some of the best
notifications of any operating system
out there period mobile or desktop and
today they took notifications again to a
new level you can actually now take
action on your notifications from the
notification tray so you can pull them
down and be able to answer texts and
call people back and snooze appointments
all from the notification tray without
ever opening any applications and
there's also a brand new and this is the
biggest thing I think is a brand new
redesign of the Search app and Ice Cream
Sandwich to now move up to jellybean
this brings a new user interface called
the cards UI and basically these are
different cards that will give you
different answers to questions and
things and these cards will get smarter
and be able to recommend things and just
get better adapted to you as it moves on
and it takes information from your
google search history and all that kind
of stuff
Google Voice Search is essentially a
Syria it's not conversational really yet
but it's definitely definitely a Siri
competitor finally for Android just
built in natively
Google you can ask a questions using
voice search and it is lightning-fast
ridiculously fast gets the answers back
to you almost as if there's no wait time
at all they answer some questions like
you know translating things and asking
what's the highest you know point in a
certain place or the height of a tower
or the distance to a place or the best
restaurant all these things that you've
been able to ask Siri on the iPhone you
are now able to interact with this cards
UI in the new Google search in Android
4.1 they also have this part of it
that's called Google now and basically
all this system is designed to just
figure you out you know uses your
location and looks at your calendar and
says oh you're about 20 minutes away
from this next calendar appointment you
should leave in five minutes
stuff like that it's really into it if
you arrive at the airport and you have a
flight in your calendar it'll keep you
up to date on how long you have before
you have to arrive at the gate it'll
tell you if that flight is delayed or
not if you're using a mass transit route
it'll tell you when the next bus arrives
when you're standing at a bus stop it'll
figure out your favorite sports teams
based on what you've already Google
searched and will keep you up to date on
the games that they're playing it'll
have a card just for the sports team so
overall Android 4.1 is a very solid
upgrade for only 0.1 upgrade over 4.0
it's a very solid upgrade and rolling
out in mid-july to the Galaxy Nexus the
Nexus S and the Motorola Xoom
and another device that were about to
talk about they got to the good stuff
right afterwards which was basically the
Nexus 7 this has been a rumor that
everyone's been talking about recently
it's the 7-inch Nexus tablet that Google
is finally announcing and releasing very
soon so we've never had a true Nexus
tablet I mean the Motorola Xoom is
running stock Android but it's not a
Nexus device so now this is a 7-inch
tablet with a Tegra 3 quad-core
processor a 1280 by 800 display and
Android 4.1 jelly bean they argue that
the seven inch form factor is very very
lightweight and very thin and it's kind
of like the size of an actual paperback
book which makes sense should have nine
hours of battery and 300 hours of
standby time which I'll have to see to
believe
it's a Wi-Fi only model it comes in
black I didn't see a white version in
the Play Store but there is a black
version I'll have all the links down in
the description you can buy this right
now for $199
watchout Kindle Fire it because this is
drained directly at you oh and this is
also the first device to ship with
Chrome as a stock browser solid so I
noticed as they were going through the
Android 4.1 demo everything had a very
nice polished look to it I know Ice
Cream Sandwich is the first operating
system from Android that really looks
like it has the most polished to it but
4.1 has these new animations you know
the new notifications like I mentioned
and everything as they were demoing it
just seemed really really responsive and
really fast so I think I was a
combination of project butter and the
optimization for higher core chips maybe
quad-core chips and dual-core chips now
have full optimizations so I'm proud of
what I've seen there at Google i/o for
the Android front and there's been a
whole bunch of other different minor
updates recently they also announced
some interesting things like the Nexus Q
which is sort of a multimedia system
that you can connect other devices to
you connect it to your TV to your
speaker and you can have other devices
connecting to it it runs 300 bucks it
seems very very tough buy it's gonna be
a tough sell but that's also in the Play
Store at the link in the description and
there are also some really neat Google+
updates as there is an events feature
now where you can have all sorts of
people connected to an event and you
turn on this thing called party mode
when you're in an event and you'll be
able to automatically upload the
pictures you take during the event all
the way up to the Google+ events page
which is pretty cool there's also a new
Google Plus tablet application which has
a brand new UI and a whole bunch of
different features which look really
cool and then suddenly they're
demonstrating this ridiculously awesome
Google glass demonstration where they
have these guys up in this blimp and
they suddenly skydive in wingsuits down
to the roof of the building then they
hand off this package to these guys who
BMX bike to the edge of the roof then
these guys rappel down the side of the
building and hop into the third floor
and bike down the center of the aisle to
get up onto the stage that is by far the
most badass thing I have ever seen at
any keynote from any company ever and
all that was just to introduce Google
glass which is a pretty interesting
project to say the least it's been
coming along well and are actually going
to be offering those to Google i/o
attendees which will be shipping early
next year and you can buy them for
$1,500 if you went to the conference
overall it was quite the conference I
was excited to watch it live and if you
want to see it I'll hopefully be able to
get a full link to watch the entire
thing at the Lincoln
description the most exciting thing for
me was the Nexus 7 tablet I'm guessing
it was you can give a thumbs up if you
agree for the same thing for you to if
not go ahead and leave a comment say
what else you find attractive about what
Google announced today I think it's a
combination of the Nexus 7 and Android
4.1 either way thanks for watching this
video hopefully you enjoyed my Galaxy s3
review which I recently uploaded and a
whole bunch of other videos that I put
out recently you can feel free to check
those out and I will talk to you guys in
the next video thanks for watching guys
hey
[Music]
you
[Music]